The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK, welcome back.
So last week, we spent the week
talking about policy search
methods, and trying to make
a distinction between those
and the value-based
methods we started with.
And by the end of the
week, we had a couple
pretty slick methods
for optimizing
an open-loop trajectory
of the system.
So we talked about
at least two ways.
So by open-loop, I mean
it's a function of time,
not a function of state.
We talked about the
shooting methods,
where we evaluated J of alpha
x0 times 0 just by simulation.
And we evaluated-- explicitly
evaluated the gradients by--
well, I gave you two
algorithms for it.
I gave you one that I called
back prop through time--
which was an adjoint method--
and another one
that I called RTRL--
real-time recurrent
learning, which
are the names from the
neural network community,
but perfectly good
names for those methods.
And then the claim
was that, if you
can compute those two
things by simulation or--
forward simulation and then
a back propagation pass,
or a simulation, which carried
also the derivatives forward
in time, then we could
hand those gradients
to SNOPT or some other
non-linear optimization
package.
And if we're good, we
can also lean on SNOPT
to handle things like
final value constraints.
If you want to make sure
the trajectory succeeds
in getting you
exactly to the goal
or if you want to make sure that
your torques are never bigger
than some maximum
talk allowed, then you
can take advantage of that.
And the second method, remember,
was direct co-location method,
which we often
abbreviate as DIRCOL.
And the big idea there
was to over-parameterized
our optimization with the
open-loop trajectory, but also
the state trajectory,
which makes coming up
with gradients simple.
And then I have to enforce
the constraint that x of--
let's say, in
discrete time here,
n plus 1 had better be
subject to the dynamics--
so two very similar
methods of trying
to compute some
open-loop trajectory
as a function of time.
Ultimately, what I care
about is a set of actions
that I apply over time that
will get me to the goal
or minimize my cost function.
In the case where I
explicitly parameterized
an open-loop trajectory,
both of these results
in a solution which satisfies
the Pontryagin minimum
principle, subject
to discretization
errors and things like that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: We did, right.
So I should say, subject
to time discretization.
That's the one place
where technically, it
would satisfy a discrete
time version of Pontryagin's
minimum principle.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: You
can think of it
whichever way it
makes you happier--
so in fact, the parameters
that you hand in--
maybe it's easier to think
of it as a function--
a discrete function of time,
because you're going to hand it
u at certain points in time,
and you're going to handle x--
hand it x at certain
points in time.
And this discrete time update
can be an Euler integration
or a higher order integration
of your continuous dynamics,
but you only satisfy
the constraints
of discrete intervals of time.
Yeah.
OK, I did give you a
slightly more general--
I tried to point out that these
methods could equally well
compute, find good parameters of
a feedback control or something
too.
The simple case was
when my parameters alpha
were explicitly my
control tape, but more
generally, if you wanted
to tune a feedback
controller-- a linear
feedback controller,
or a non-linear
or a neural network,
or whatever it is,
you can use the same
methods to do that.
I would only make this
statement in the case
where the controller
specifically
is the open-loop tape,
because if I parameterized
my trajectory by some feedback
controller, for instance,
then that's going to
restrict the policy class.
That's going to restrict
the class of tapes
that I can look over, which
makes it a more compact, more
efficient way to solve
your optimization,
but potentially prevents
you from achieving
a perfect minimum.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yep.
So by virtue of saying
that they satisfy
Pontryagin's minimum
principle, we
know that that's
only a local optima.
This says that I can't
make a small change in u
to get better performance.
Yep.
But it's only a necessary
condition for optimality, not
a sufficient one.
But there's a bigger problem
with it-- with both of those.
And that's the fact
that they're completely
useless in real
life, unless I do
one more step, which is to
stabilize the trajectory as I
get out.
So finding some open-loop
trajectory by these methods,
satisfying Pontryagin's
minimum principle-- fine.
But there's nothing in
this process that says,
if I don't-- if I changed my
initial conditions by epsilon,
I could completely
diverge when I follow--
when I execute that
open-loop trajectory.
If I change my simulation
time step by a little bit,
I might diverge.
If I have modeling
errors, I might diverge.
So in order to make these
useful for a real system,
we have to do
another step, which
is trajectory stabilization.
And it actually follows quite
naturally from the things
we've already talked about.
OK, so today we're going
to give these guys teeth
with a trajectory optimization.
And I'll show you
examples of a trajectory
that's optimized beautifully
for the pendulum even,
and if I simulate it a
little differently back--
just does the wrong thing.
It never gets to the top.
So we want to get
rid of that problem.
OK, so the solution is to design
a trajectory stabilization.
Now, for those of
you that have been
playing with robots
for many years, when
you hear trajectory
stabilization,
what do you think of?
What kind of tricks
to people use
for trajectory stabilization?
AUDIENCE: Sliding surfaces.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Sliding surfaces--
that's a good one for--
[INAUDIBLE] often will
design a sliding surface
and squish the aerodynamics.
That's actually
pretty encompassing.
I think a lot of the
trajectory stabilizers
are based on sliding
modes or feedback
linearization in some form.
And all I'll say about it
is that the story's sort
of the same as
everything we've said.
If you have a fully
actuated system,
it's not hard to design
a trajectory stabilizer.
A good sliding mode
controller could take--
could work even for an
underactuated system,
but I think there's a--
I prefer the linear
quadratic form
of these trajectories
stabilizers.
OK, so we want to do a
trajectory stabilization that's
suitable for
underactuated systems.
And the approach is
going to be with LQR.
OK, so if we're
going to use LQR,
we better be able to
linearize our system.
So far, when we've done
the linearizations,
we've only done them
at fixed points.
So the first thing
we have to ask
ourselves is, what happens if
we try to linearize at a more
arbitrary point in state space?
Yeah.
So let's say I've got the
system x dot equals f of xu,
and now I want to linearize
around some x0, u0, but not
necessarily a carefully
chosen x0, u0--
just something random
in state space.
The Taylor expansion
of this says
that this thing's going
to be approximately
f of x0, u0, partial f,
partial x evaluated at x.
OK, and we called this
before A and this B,
and so that thing we can
actually write as, in general,
in the case where f
of x0, u0-- if x0,
u0 was a fixed
point of the system,
that term disappears,
but be careful.
If you're doing your
linearization out here,
if you're at-- not
at a fixed point,
if you have any
velocity, for instance,
then, in the original
x-coordinates,
it's not actually-- the Taylor
expansion doesn't give you
a linear system.
It gives you some affine system.
This thing is harder
to work with-- not
incredibly harder, but
harder to work with.
The solution is quite
simple, but I just
wanted to say it
the bad way first
so that you appreciate
the good way.
If we change coordinates
and we use instead
for our coordinates the
difference between x and x0
of t, then x bar dot is going
to be x dot minus x0 dot
equals x dot minus f of
x0, u0, which is that C.
This guy here is taken care of
in this new coordinate system,
which allows me to write
the whole thing as x
bar dot equals A of x bar.
You with me on that?
Linearizing a system at
a more arbitrary point--
doing a Taylor expansion
results in a linear system
only if you change
coordinates to lie
on some system trajectory.
So x0, u0 must be a solution of
x of f of xu of that equation.
And then the system reduces to
a linear system description.
But the cost you pay for
this beautiful, simple--
well, let me be even a
little bit more careful.
So A here, this
partial f, partial x,
is evaluated at xt u of t.
And in general,
A and B in this--
when I do this are functions
of time, as well as x and t.
That's a pretty important point.
So if I'm willing to change
coordinates to live along
the trajectory, then the
result is I can get this linear
time-varying model of the
dynamics along feasible
trajectories--
system trajectories.
The cost is that
you have to work
in a coordinate system that
moves along your trajectory.
So we'll see where that
comes in in a little bit.
But the first question is, OK,
let's say I've got this linear
time-varying--
time-varying linear system.
Can I do all the things
I want to do with that?
In most of our control classes,
we end up doing LTI systems.
LTV systems-- linear
time-varying--
are actually a fantastically
rich class of systems
that we don't talk about
enough, I think, in life.
They're still linear systems.
Superposition still holds.
If I have initial
condition 1 and some u
trajectory 1 for t
greater than equal to t0,
and that gives me some
resulting x trajectory out
for t greater than t0, and
I have another solution
with a different
initial condition
and a different control, and
that gives me a different--
I call this x1, x2 for t
greater than or equal to t0--
if I have that,
then it better be
the case that alpha 1 x1
of t0 plus alpha 2 x2 of t0
plus alpha 1 u1 tape
plus alpha 2 u2 tape
is going to result
in a trajectory which
is alpha 1 x1 plus alpha 2 x2.
That's superposition.
That's the defining
characteristic of linearity.
And even though this is a
richer class of systems--
these A of t, x of
t, B of t, u of t--
superposition still holds.
And in fact, a lot
of our derivations
that we've done that are for
linear systems still hold.
OK, so now the question
is, how do we design--
how do we work with the fact
that this thing is still easy,
and design a
controller that works
with this new linearized system?
Maybe first I should break out
my colored chalk and make sure
we have intuition about this.
Do you understand
what this is doing,
if I do this time-varying
linearization?
Let me do an example
with the pendulum
here, our favorite
theta, theta dot.
And let's say we carve up--
we find some nice solution which
gets me from my one fixed point
to the other fixed point.
The ones we were getting were
these pump-up trajectories,
which looked
something like this.
I'm moving through
state space here,
and the dynamics here vary
with state in a non-linear way.
But if I have a trajectory,
a feasible trajectory
that goes through the
relevant parts of state space,
then this time-varying
linearization takes
my non-linear system, and
makes it parameterized
only-- instead of by being
parameterized by state,
it's going to make
it parameterized only
by time along the trajectory.
The trick is the
trajectory allows
me to reparameterize my
non-linearity in terms of time,
instead of state.
It sounds like a simple thing--
I'm just reparameterizing it--
but it makes all the
difference in the world.
If things are parameterized
as a function of time,
and are otherwise linear,
then I could do all kinds
of computation on them.
I can integrate the equations.
I can design quadratic
regulators on it.
It makes all the
difference in the world.
So what I'm effectively
doing is coming up
with local linear
representations of the dynamics
along the trajectory.
I'm not sure if this is a
helpful way for me to draw it,
but you can think of this thing
as approximating the dynamics
along that trajectory.
At every given
instant in time, I'm
going to use one of
these linear models.
This is supposed
to be some plane
that you're driving through--
not sure if that's
actually helpful
graphic, but it's the
way I think of it.
And by virtue of taking a
particular path through,
I can make locally linear
models on which these things
have eigenvectors,
and eigenvalues,
or whatever that are
valid in the neighborhood
of the trajectory.
So if you can imagine, even
without any stabilization,
it could be that I
could quickly assess
the stability of my
time-varying linear model.
And trajectories in
this linear model
may converge to the
nominal limit cycle,
or they may diverge,
depending on A and B.
Or they may blow up.
This is by far the more
common case, unfortunately.
You'd be very lucky to come
out of a shooting method
or a direct co-location method,
and end up with a system
where if you played it
out, it just happened
to be a stable trajectory.
But we can assess
all that quickly
with these time-varying
linearizations found locally.
Make sense?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
talk about that there
is a bad way of doing this.
This is not a bad way
of doing this, right?
We were talkinga about it.
RUSS TEDRAKE: If I do a
Taylor expansion of my system
in the original coordinate
system, which is x,
then it's not linear.
End parentheses, that
was the bad way to do it.
Yeah?
Good way to do it--
change the coordinates to
a coordinate system, which
moves with the trajectory.
If you do that, things
become time-varying linear.
That was a good way to
do it, and that's still
in open parentheses.
We're still going.
Yeah.
OK, so our task now is to
design a time-varying feedback
controller-- since our
model is time-varying,
you'd expect our solution
to also be time-varying--
which takes these bad, unstable
trajectories of the system--
and they really are--
I'll show you simple pendulum.
This trajectory comes out.
Actually, if you just
integrate in a different way,
it'll go off and
do the wrong thing.
It typically doesn't go off
and add energy to the system
so much.
The ones I get--
I see, I'll show you, are more--
they diverge and the other way,
and end up just floating around
here, for instance.
But they're not going
to get you up here.
So can we design a
time-varying stabilizer
that regulates that trajectory?
OK, I did actually do the
original finite horizon LQR
derivation on the
board that day--
definitely won't write
all that again, but let
me say that roughly nothing
in that derivation breaks--
I'm going to show you
the important pieces--
nothing in that derivation
breaks, surprisingly,
if A and B are now
a function of time.
So let's remember that--
the LQR derivation.
Now I'm working with this
x bar coordinate system.
And I want to design
a cost function
to minimize here, which lives
in this coordinate system
again here.
Let's say it's the
final horizon times Qf--
I've been trying
to use t little f,
since my transposes look
like the final horizon time
otherwise--
0 to tf dt x bar--
again, transpose
Q plus u bar Ru.
OK, in the original
LQR derivation,
we guessed that the form--
that the optimal policy had
the form x bar S of t x bar.
That's still intact.
That's still a good assumption.
This thing's linear.
It's just in a different
coordinate system.
And we started cranking through
the sufficiency theorem,
the Hamilton-Jacobi-Bellman
equation.
And we found that our
optimal feedback policy--
first of all, our
optimal cost-to-go
was described by this
Riccati equation, which
was negative S of t
is Q minus S of t B
our inverse B transpose S of t
plus S of t A plus A transpose
S of t.
And it turns out that,
with the-- if you have
a time-varying A
and B, that it's--
exact same dynamics govern it.
You just have your time
dependence also in A and B.
And that exact same
Riccati equation works,
and our final value
condition was just Qf.
And you can see from this, if it
didn't make a difference for me
when A and B became
functions of time,
it's pretty simple-- although
less interesting, I guess.
If Q were to be a function
of time-- no problem.
If R was a function
They still have to be positive
definite and symmetric.
Oops-- I did it the wrong way.
Q can be 0, but R can not be 0.
OK, so the LQR
you know and love,
that you've used in Matlab,
is the time invariant infinite
horizon LQR.
I told you that, if you
cared about a finite horizon
and you had a time invariant
linear system, then
suddenly you had to--
you couldn't just find the
stationary points in this.
Remember, Matlab's solution
just tells you the long-term
behavior of S. In the time--
finite horizon time,
even the LTI case,
which is the A and B
do not depend on time--
the linear time invariant case--
I still had to integrate back
this Riccati equation in order
to get my LQR controller.
It's no more expensive
to do the same thing
in the linear time-varying
feedback case.
And the resulting
controller is--
u star is my nominal controller
minus my R inverse B transpose
S of t x bar.
These equations come
up enough that these
are pretty famous, pretty
important equations, and so I--
those I know off
the top of my head.
They come up all the time.
And this is the resulting
optimal trajectory,
which is my nominal trajectory
plus my feedback gain, which
came out of my original
LQR controller,
if you remember that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yes-- good.
I should definitely put
a T under B. Thank you.
I haven't written that case,
but R could equally well
be time-dependent.
OK, so something
big just happened.
I can take a really, really
complicated non-linear system
along some trajectory-- if
I find a good trajectory,
then I can actually
linearize that system
along this trajectory
and stabilize it.
The thing I haven't convinced
you of yet-- because I only
know how to do it
from showing examples,
but it really works well.
So even though it's
a linear system--
it's a linear approximation
of the non-linear system,
something like the [INAUDIBLE]
or the cartpole swing-up.
It's got a huge
basin of attraction.
Lots and lots of
initial conditions
will find their way to the
trajectory and get to the goal.
If you want to do non-linear
control of a humanoid robot
or something like this, this
actually scales pretty nicely.
I just have to
solve this equation.
S is the size--
is a matrix that's
by number of states.
But I could do that
in 30 dimensions.
That's no problem.
And even for very
non-linear systems,
local linear feedback
works very, very well--
so well, in fact, that I
think that, if you ask--
and when I did ask
the [INAUDIBLE] guys,
Sasha Megretski says,
this is definitely
what I would do if I was
controlling a walking
robot or something like that.
We're trying to do the
same thing to control
neurons in a dish now.
We're trying to
build good models
of the dynamics-- time-varying
models, for instance--
and then doing this
kind of control.
Yeah.
It works really, really well.
The only complaint
about it is that it's
going to have-- it's based
on this linear approximation,
so it will have a finite
basin of attraction.
For some systems,
it can be quite big.
If you have systems with
hard non-linearities,
it won't be as big.
Later in the course,
I'll show you
ways to explicitly reason
about the size of those basins
of attraction, but
today let's just
say this is a good
thing to know,
good thing to have
in your pocket.
Let me show you a working--
try to convince you
that it's pretty good.
OK, so let's see where
I've left myself here.
I took this-- the pendulum--
let's do the shooting version.
They both work fine, but
Is that bigger than
I did last time?
That's pretty obnoxious.
Maybe it's always
been obnoxious.
Can we get away with that?
Yeah.
You guys are like,
I'm not blind.
OK.
So I showed you last
time the shooting code.
It comes out with a
resulting tape x, t, and u.
After the result of these
trajectory optimizers,
whether it's shooting
or whether it's
direct co-location--
whatever it is--
it comes up with
some open-loop tape.
I put x in there too just to--
as the reference trajectory
that results, but
what really matters
is the time stamps and u
command, the open-loop tape.
Why don't I save it this time?
OK, so it comes
up-- in this case,
with these parameters
I've chosen,
comes up with some
one-pump policy.
With the torque limits I
have, the [INAUDIBLE] I have,
it comes up with a one-pump
policy that gets me
to the top in four seconds.
OK, let me now just simulate
that a little bit differently.
So the only thing I'm
going to do here now is--
this control_ode is just a
simulation which plays back
exactly the same open-loop
tape, but it plays it back
with a little more
careful integration--
because in the actual-- in
the shooting code I used,
I used the big time step just
so I don't waste time computing
gradients to the n-th
degree of accuracy.
That's not worthwhile.
If I simulate the
exact same thing back
with a more careful
ode integration,
let's see what happens.
So that was that same
trajectory that--
exact same control inputs,
just simulated more carefully.
It made its honest
effort to get up there,
but it didn't
quite get up there,
turned around, and
came back down.
I'm trying to show
it also in just--
this is the different state
trajectories over time.
You can see that the
red and blue lines
are the desired versus actual
in the-- in theta, in this case.
And these two lines
are the desired versus
actual in theta dot.
They start off exactly
on top of each other,
but just little
differences in the numerics
causes them to go in
different directions--
part ways.
OK, so now I've got
this LTV LQR solution,
which is exactly what
I just showed you.
So I was just simulating
a just now with just u
being the nominal u.
Now I'm going to add this
time-varying feedback term,
x minus x desired.
And now my more
careful integration
results in a closed-loop system,
which not only got to the goal,
but actually stayed up
at the goal, because I
have a stable system
all the way to the top.
OK?
All right, so what I just
said was very unimpressive.
I said I computed a open-loop
policy with my methods
from Thursday.
I simulated them back.
They didn't work.
But I then put a
feedback controller
on, and from the exact
same initial conditions,
I now can simulate
them, and they work.
So it's disappointing that
we had to do that at all,
but I can now--
the stability is more
than just stabilizing
the initial conditions.
Let's add some fairly
big random numbers
to that initial condition
and see what happens.
It's recomputing the
policy every time,
just because it was
fast enough that I
didn't bother to change it.
OK, so that actually
started with pretty big
different initial conditions.
So theta was off by--
I don't know-- 2/10 of a
radian or something like this.
The velocities were off by
1/2 a radian per second.
We could crank that up.
I bet it does a lot
better than that.
But if you watch
these things, they
converge quite nicely to
together at the end there.
And what matters is
they get up to the top.
So again, these things come
together, find their way up
to the top, and live.
I bet, if I put it a lot
bigger, it'll still work.
I normally do an
order of magnitude,
but let's not be silly.
Oh-- didn't make it.
There's only one reason it
didn't make it, actually.
It's because, if
you look in here,
I'm actually honest about
implementing the max torques.
Yeah.
So I actually have a
torque limit, I impose it,
and it lives on there.
If I didn't, I bet
I could convince you
it works for any
initial condition.
But let's try it one more
time-- get a little more lucky
with the initial conditions.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
Yes.
OK, that was pretty far off, and
it's still found its way back
to the trajectory.
Good-- yeah?
Look at how big those
initial conditions are.
There and there versus--
wow, that's really good.
OK.
Did I see a question?
No?
All right, so this stuff
works for pendulum.
It works for more
interesting systems too.
I'll just show you the
cartpole real quick here.
I won't do the--
here is what it looks
like without feedback.
I'll just do the initial
conditions corrupted solution,
pump up--
OK, so if you remember my
solutions from last time,
I never drove off
the screen before,
so that it was actually it
catching it by deviating enough
that it came off
the screen, and then
slowly coming back to the top.
It must be its x position
or something going way off.
No, not x position--
what is that?
That's my control.
Yeah.
Did I do torque
limits on that one?
I still did torque limits.
I just set them high, I guess.
Yeah.
So it really works.
And the cool thing is
the cost of implementing
that LQR LTV stabilizer
was negligibly
more than implementing the--
most of that time was the
shooting optimization.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why do you
always start at the 0 time?
You could look at the
initial conditions
and look where is
the closest point
on my nominal trajectories and
then do your control policy
from that moment in time.
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK.
So that's a really, really good.
OK, that's exactly what I want
to talk about next, actually.
I designed a time-varying
feedback controller,
is negative K of t x bar of t.
I designed that ahead of time.
And then, from the
initial conditions,
I started simulating from 0,
and I just played out the--
my nominal trajectory just
marched forward with time,
my feedback controller just
and my aerodynamics just
marched forward with time.
OK, so before I explicitly
address your question,
let me point out--
let me ask even a
simpler question here.
If I had plotted that in state
space, what you would have seen
is that the trajectory starts
off somewhere in state space
and comes together.
That would have a good idea.
Maybe I should do
that in a minute.
But it comes together and finds
its way onto that trajectory.
Yeah?
OK, so here's the question.
Instead of just changes
in initial conditions,
what happens if I
have disturbances
that push me off the trajectory?
Well, that's OK.
That's no different really than
a different initial condition.
They'll come back on here.
What happens if I have
a disturbance that
pushes me along the trajectory
with this controller?
Let's say I've got the
helpful disturbance, which,
when I was right
here, just happened
to push me right to there.
What's my feedback
controller going to do?
AUDIENCE: Slow it down.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah-- probably
in a dramatic fashion.
It's the same way-- it tries
to quickly converge from here.
It's going to push itself back
towards that point, possibly.
Slowing down doesn't--
makes it sound--
no big deal.
It can't go backwards,
but it might
try to do something more
severe to try to catch up
with that old trajectory.
So the major limitation of
this is that it's blindly--
in order to have the strong
convergence properties
that we have, the controller
is blindly marching forward
in time.
The great thing about switching
to a time parameterization
I can compute everything--
everything's linear again.
The bad thing is
you're a slave to time.
So Phillip asked
a next question.
He says, so why not--
why do I just blindly start
marching forward from time 0?
Maybe, if I have a
controller, I should just
look for the closest
point in my trajectory,
and then, instead of
indexing off time,
index off some sort of phase,
some fraction of my trajectory,
and then execute
that controller.
And you can do that.
I wish you the best
if you do that,
but my suspicion is
that, if on every dt,
you pick the closest
point in the trajectory,
then the result is you're going
to chatter like you wouldn't
believe.
So there's a lot of
protection you get when you--
you could think
of this very much
as a gain-scheduled
linear controller.
This is a time-varying
gain scheduling,
and the problem is if
I switch gain quickly,
then you're going
to get chattering.
So it might make a lot
of sense, for instance,
if you were to get a big
disturbance, to re-evaluate,
and try to find
the closest point,
and start executing that new
policy with time re-indexed.
But it's probably a bad
idea, in my experience,
to decide which part
of the trajectory
you're closest to on every--
every dt.
That's probably a bad idea.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Could you
maybe play some tricks
if you had some idea of
the basin of attraction
of the current point
you're trying to get to?
And if you know that
you're outside of it,
then work around
it, [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yes.
So I have a particular trick
the does that does that in--
we'll talk about it in
the motion planning, but--
yeah, so Mark knows
about these tricks
for computing basins of
attraction pretty efficiently.
And so these days what
we do is we actually
try to compute the funnel--
the basin of attraction
of this trajectory
around the trajectory, and
you could know discretely
if you left that
basin of attraction.
So I'll give you
the recipe for that,
but it actually
makes more sense,
I think, in the motion planning
context, where we actually
will design
trajectories that fill
the space with these basins.
This is very similar to
the concept of flow tubes.
Yes.
OK, so big idea--
turn my non-linear system into
a linear time-varying system,
because I've re-parameterized
it that along the trajectory.
Do linear time-varying control,
and even really complicated
systems-- it'll work well.
We're doing on our
[INAUDIBLE] plane.
I mean, it's really
a pretty good idea.
When I first started
working with it,
I thought that it would
have the problem that--
it would have the property
that it uses a lot of control
to force itself back
to the trajectory
and rigidly follow
the trajectory.
It's easy to equate
linear control
with high-gain linear feedback,
which people do a lot of,
but it doesn't necessarily
need that property.
If R is small in
this derivation,
it can actually take very
subtle approaches back
to the trajectory.
Your system might come
in and do whatever
it needs to get back on
the trajectory with very
little torque.
The only price you pay is,
if your torque is smaller,
if you're penalizing
torque use higher,
then you might restrict
your-- that might shrink
your basin of attraction.
It might be that, because it's
trying to use less torque,
it will not overcome
the non-linearities.
But in the neighborhood
of the trajectory,
you can get these
very elegant solutions
which look like minimal
energy kind of solutions
for the non-linear
problem in the vicinity
of these trajectories.
So one of the ideas we'll
talk about later is how do you
design the minimal set
of trajectories-- which,
if you use these controllers,
which do the right thing
in a lot of places--
if you walked away from
this class knowing nothing
but direct co-location and
linear time-varying feedback
control, I bet you could
control a lot of cool systems.
Yeah.
I guess you also have to
know sys id, which I'm not
going to tell you about.
That's the gotcha.
You have to have a model
for all this stuff.
If someone gives you
a model, if you're
willing to construct a model,
then you can do a lot of things
with this.
OK, I want to give you
one more mental picture
to think about what this
is doing so it launches
into the next thing here.
So my cost-to-go function, which
I just erased, is, remember--
my cost-to-go function, J of x
bar t, is x bar S of t x bar.
This is a quadratic form.
Just like the original
LQR, you can think
of this as a quadratic bowl.
In the LTI LQR case--
am I OK throwing around
these three-letter acronyms?
In the LTI LQR case, it
was a static quadratic bowl
centered around the point
I'm trying to stabilize--
so my cost-to-go.
It said-- says, as I move
away from the point I'm trying
to regulate, I'm going to incur
more cost in the direction--
the rate it grows depends
on the variables inside S.
Now, in this picture, I
have still a time-varying--
I have a time-varying
quadratic bowl,
but it's also
moving through time,
because it's based on x bar.
So in my pendulum world, if I
have this nominal trajectory,
you can think of it as having
some quadratic bowl here.
And the LTI stabilizer
that we did come up
with that was based
on LQR did have
some sort of quadratic bowl
shape that looked like that.
Backwards in time, there's going
to be another quadratic bowl.
Can I draw it very
badly like this?
If I can just draw coming off
the board a little bit-- so
there's some quadratic bowl
centered around this point,
which is my costs-to-go.
At that point, if I marched
further backwards in time,
I've got some other quadratic
bowl around this point.
That makes the
point, again, that--
if my quadratic
ball is currently
this because time is 5--
or I had a 4-second trajectory--
maybe times 3 here--
and I'm pushed along
the trajectory,
it's actually going to
incur just as much cost,
roughly, as I'm pushed
another direction.
There's a quadratic bowl
literally centered around x0
at time t.
That's what this equation says.
And this quadratic bowl is
the cost-to-go estimate.
It says, if I'm away
from the trajectory,
I should expect the cost
I incur in getting back
towards that trajectory
to be this quadratic form.
Is that OK?
And the key point is,
because I've re-parameterized
my equations in terms of x
bar, this quadratic bowl always
lives on that trajectory.
My cost function
was x bar Q x bar.
My best thing to
do is to drive x
bar to 0, which means
to drive my system back
to the trajectory.
People OK with that imagery?
It doesn't look like they are.
Everybody's OK.
Are we OK here
the LTI stabilizer
being an LQR bowl--
or a quadratic bowl?
So the farther I am away in
the directions defined by S,
I'm going to cut some
cost getting back.
This is just the
same thing that says,
if I'm at this point
in the trajectory,
I'm going to cover
this cost-to-go.
And the best thing to do,
the minimal cost-to-go
is living right on
that trajectory.
As a consequence, the
optimal controller,
which tries to go down the
landscape of the cost-to-go,
is going to drive you
back to the trajectory.
Now, I said all that because
I'm about to do something
that sounds totally wacky.
Would it ever make sense for me
to design a slightly different
cost function, which, when
I linearize and design
the feedback controller, I end
up with a cost-to-go over here?
Let's say I have some
nominal trajectory.
I found, through
whatever method,
some reasonable system
trajectory, but I really--
I'm still not happy with that.
The trajectory I really wanted
was something like this,
let's say.
Would it make any sense
to do my linearization
around this trajectory,
and try to drive the system
to this other trajectory?
AUDIENCE: You mean like scaling
your optimal trajectory?
RUSS TEDRAKE: I don't
even mean scaling.
They could cross.
They could do whatever.
It's not a simple scaling.
Let me give you a simpler
version of the problem.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Say that again.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yes.
I'm going to divine a
cost function, which
would have it so I prefer
to live on that trajectory.
Let me do it in the
time invariant case
just so it's clear.
Let's say my coordinate
system's back and simple.
It lives around 0.
Let's say I have that
cost function, or actually
that dynamics.
And instead of-- my original
cost function was just x
transpose Qx--
let's say my cost
function now is--
let's think about this
problem for a second.
So let's say I have
a linear system.
Now, the LQR controller
we did initially--
little sloppy with that.
The LQR controller
I did initially
always assumed that the desired
place you wanted to be in life
was 0.
If the desired place you want
to be in life is a constant--
it's 3, let's say--
then you can still do your
linear quadratic regulator.
Just move your coordinate
system so the 3 is 0.
But let's say I've
got a linear system,
but I want to drive it
through some trajectory--
time-varying trajectory-- x
desired as a function of time.
Then I can't quite just
recenter the origin.
I've got to think
about, how do I
drive my linear system through
some other trajectories?
Now the-- it's actually--
LTI system, but my cost function
is time-varying, because my--
I have the desired trajectory
that varies with time.
The result-- I won't
write it down again--
again, I can do this
Riccati equation.
Back up.
The only difference is
that the quadratic bowl
is no longer going to be
centered on the origin.
The quadratic bowl is going
to move with that desired
trajectory.
OK?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If that's far away
from where you linearized,
could you--
RUSS TEDRAKE: That's
an excellent question.
But this is a linear
system, so first, we
don't have to worry
about that, but don't let
me forget to go back to that.
So I can drive my linear system
through some trajectory that's
non-zero beautifully
with an LQR controller.
The only problem is
that my LQR controller
has to have has a cost-to-go
function and a controller which
is not pointing me
always at the origin.
You wouldn't want that.
So in fact, the way it
looks-- there's a lot of ways
that people derive it.
With Pontryagin, it's
not too hard to derive.
I prefer to derive
it with the HJB.
I'm not going to do
the derivation, but--
I don't mean to bore
you, but what you end up
with is J of x of t has a form
x transpose S of t x plus x
transpose--
I call this S2--
S1 of t plus S0 of t.
It's a full quadratic form.
When I just have this, it's
always a quadratic bowl.
It's always centered around 0.
If you want it, in general,
to be a quadratic bowl that's
not necessarily at 0, you
need the full quadratic form.
I could equally well
have written this
as x minus x something
desired, S of t.
But let's work with this form.
Yeah?
So this is just an equation of a
quadratic bowl, not necessarily
centered on the origin.
And the LQR derivation gives me
my backwards dynamics for S2.
It gives me the backwards
dynamics for S1 and for S0.
And it's in the notes.
It's actually already
in your notes.
It's in the HJB chapter that
has been up there for a while.
OK, now, the reason
I'm on about all this
is that there's another way--
I told you about
shooting methods.
direct co-location.
There is yet another
way that people
like to design trajectories,
which use LQR directly.
And that's this
iterative LQR procedure.
OK.
So let's say I have some
trajectory that I've already
found, x 0 of t, and I have
some different trajectory, which
is my desired trajectory,
x desired of t.
Then, using this
optimal tracking--
if you stick back in the
time-varying components,
using this optimal
tracking, I can
linearize my dynamical
system around that.
So I have no guarantees
that x desired
is a feasible trajectory.
In fact, many cases-- it's not.
For instance, x desired might
be B at the goal at all times.
If I came up with a perfectly
feasible x desired trajectory,
I probably wouldn't be
running an open-loop solver.
I want to get to I want to
get as close as desired--
as possible to the x
desired while potentially
minimizing cost and respecting
the dynamics of the system.
Here's one way to do it--
linearize my system around
my initial guess, x0 of t,
then design a linear
optimal tracking--
linear time-varying
optimal tracking which
tries to regulate my
system as close as
possible to that trajectory.
Now, what Steven said
was exactly on point.
If I drive my system away
from where I linearized,
there's no guarantee
that my linear model
is going to be any good here.
But the hope is that this
trajectory is better--
a better guess than
the one before.
And you iterate, make another
approximation around there,
design the LQR controller, run
the LQR controller that drives
me here to find the new u tape.
That defines my new
trajectory-- repeat.
OK?
That's called iterative LQR.
What else is it called?
Do you know?
Yeah.
Do you see that?
It's differential
dynamic programming--
almost.
There's a subtle difference,
which I can tell you,
if you want.
There's a lot of names for it.
There's another guy, Bobrow--
some of you know Jim Bobrow--
he wrote this up called the
sequential linear quadratic
regulators.
Any four-letter acronym
that ends in LQR--
if you put it in Google,
you'll find something
that's probably this idea.
Yeah.
If you put in whatever arbitrary
constant in front of it,
you'll probably
get this idea out.
AUDIENCE: What prevents
your actuator costs
from accumulating from
one iteration to another?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Every
iteration, you're
trying to minimize
your actuator cost.
AUDIENCE: Right, but I mean, if
you have a lot of iterations,
couldn't that potentially grow?
RUSS TEDRAKE: I don't
actually add to my old u tape.
I actually completely
replace my old u tape
with a new controller which
drives me to the system.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
RUSS TEDRAKE: So there's no
worries about additive actions.
It actually tells me in my
original non-linear system
what's my best guess as
a u tape that goes there.
AUDIENCE: Is this
basically a trick
to get rid of the
slow [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: So very,
very good-- so why would
I want to do this?
Why didn't I tell you
about this first, or why--
how does this compare
to the other methods?
There is a sense by which-- and
I thought about doing the whole
derivation, but I think this--
I hope that this short
discussion is sufficient.
So what I'm roughly
doing is I'm using
LQR to come up with a quadratic
approximation of where
my cost--
where my minimum is.
This is very much in
the spirit of those SQP
methods, the sequential
quadratic methods.
I'm using computation
on this line
to come up with a quadratic
approximation of where I think
the new minimum should be.
So as such, it's a relatively
cheap way with SQP properties,
convergence properties.
OK.
The methods I told you
about on Thursday--
the backprop through
time, the RTRL--
they computed J
over my trajectory.
They computed partial J, partial
alpha over my trajectory.
They did not ever explicitly
compute the second derivative.
I never computed partial J,
partial alpha, partial alpha.
To explicitly do an
SQP update, somebody
needs to compute the Hessian
of that optimization.
I'm relying on SNOPT
to do some bookkeeping
to estimate the Hessian to
do the second-order update.
I would do better if
I had an efficient way
to compute the
second derivatives,
and I could hand that
directly to SNOPT or whatever,
and we'd get-- expect
faster convergence.
This isn't quite the
gradients that I want,
but it has that feel to it,
and it has similar convergence
properties.
So what you should
think about is
you should think
about this is a more
explicit second-order
method for making
a large jump in my trajectories
with sequential quadratic
convergence results.
I feel like I've lost everybody
now, but ask questions,
if you need to.
The advantage of it
is that it's fast.
It could potentially
require very few iterations
to converge.
One of the strongest advantages
is that there's no explicit way
to do constraints.
You have to think harder about
how to do constraints in this.
And I know less
formal guarantees
that it will succeed,
because it's an approximation
of that quadratic.
So the RL community
uses DDP a lot,
and actually, a lot of
people who do DDP do
iterative LQR, for instance.
For instance, Peter
[INAUDIBLE] and those guys--
they always call DDP.
They're actually
doing iterative LQR.
DDP explicitly actually has--
you have to do a second-order
expansion of your dynamics,
so you don't just get A of t x.
You actually go to second-order
expansion of your dynamics.
So it's a little bit more
expensive of an update,
but most people equate it
almost exactly to iterative LQR.
AUDIENCE: So this
x0 trajectory, this
isn't a trajectory
you found by doing
RTRL or something like that?
This is something different?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good--
so this could be
a standard replacement to RTRL.
I could start with a
random x0 trajectory.
So maybe it's better to start
with a random u trajectory,
simulate it, and get
an x0 trajectory.
And then it will
quickly reshape until it
gets as close as possible to
this x desired trajectory.
AUDIENCE: But you're reshaping
your control actions that
get you to the x trajectory?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yes.
So I'm reshaping u,
resimulating to get the new x.
Yeah.
I wrote it more carefully
in the notes, and--
but I hope this is the
right level to do the class.
And there's one
extra thing that--
so I say this works if
you have a desired x--
desired trajectory, which
means your cost function
has this sort of a form.
The advocates of
iterative LQR and DDP
say that every cost
function has this form.
This is just a second-order
Taylor expansion
of whatever non-linear
cost function you want.
So write down whatever
non-linear cost function
you have, do a second-order
expansion on it,
and you end up with a quadratic
cost function like this.
And you can then
approximate that solution
with an iterative LQR scheme--
or RTRL, or backprop
through time.
This is the third out
of our list of methods.
My goal is only to know--
so that you know that it exists.
And you can read the
notes if you want more,
and you can read the
papers if you want more.
OK?
Yeah, Michael?
AUDIENCE: So I
think last time you
talked about you're
parallelizing the deviation
from your non-control input.
So what if you were--
like as you iterate
the controller, [INAUDIBLE]?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good-- the total
cost is actually the cost
with respect to some u desired.
So I end up trying to optimize
that in a coordinate system
based on u0, but the cost I'm
trying to minimize is the u
the original coordinate
system minus u desired--
which, in a lot of cases, is 0.
Although I do it in a
weird coordinate system,
and it actually eventually
subtracts itself out
because I add it back
in at the end, and--
it's quite easy
to, for instance,
minimize u squared in the
original coordinate system.
OK?
So on Thursday, we get
to do walking robots.
We're going to move on
to the next major thing.
But you've now learned three
of the open-loop trajectory
optimizers that
people really use--
iterative LQR very quickly,
RTRL backprop through time--
I grouped as one--
the shooting methods
and direct co-location.
There's another one
that's recent addition
to the scene, which is
this discrete mechanics
and optimal control, this DMOC.
If anybody was
excited about that
and wanted to do a
class project on that,
that would be a perfect thing.
Grab that paper.
Show us that it works on
the [INAUDIBLE] carpole.
That'd be beautiful.
I'd love to have that--
have us try that and see how it
compares to the other methods.
You've got a pretty good toolkit
for optimal control now--
practical optimal control.
And it works for flying
robots, but it also
worked for your wheeled robots,
if you want to control them
with better control.
You could do a drop-in
replacement LTI optimal
tracking controller,
and it would be better--
assuming your model's better.
So you have these tools.
Quick procedural things--
I know we're out of time.
So next Thursday-- well, so let
me say the good thing first.
In two weeks, you're
on spring break.
Yeah.
The Thursday preceding
that is our midterm.
We haven't had a midterm
in the class before,
so there's no old exams
for me to give you,
but John and I are
going to try to come up
with some representative
problems for you
to take home for
Thursday of this week
so you can have some problems
to munch on over the weekend.
It'll be an in-class exam
Thursday before spring break,
which is a week from Thursday.
OK?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yes.
So open-book-- well, you
can grab whatever notes--
open-note exam-- absolutely.
Well, I'll say it more in
the preparation package,
but roughly, we're going to--
I think, if you have
your notes with you,
if you've done the problem set--
and most importantly, if you
know how these algorithms--
where the algorithms relate to
each other and where they'd be
used in different systems--
I can guarantee I'm going to
ask you something about that--
then it's not designed
to be a killer.
Good-- and I hope you start
thinking about projects.
Just out of being a
fairly nice person,
I wasn't going to ask you to do
projects before your midterm.
But this time last year,
I was asking people
to submit project proposals.
We're going to do that
immediately after the midterm.
If you've been chewing
on, this method
looked like a really good
match to my research problem,
or I've never actually thought
about juggling robots before,
or something like
this, you can imagine--
so in the fairly
near future, we're
going to ask you for a
half-page project proposal
that we can iterate
with you on to get going
on a world-class final project.
Yeah?
See you Thursday.